olá e seu colega joão laet uma colega
brenda nós somos alunos da escola joão
goulart e estamos no sétimo ano
a nossa escola ela tem cerca de 1400
alunos à escola localizada em são
leopoldo em bairro enfrenta muitos
problemas sociais
mesmo enfrentando vários obstáculos têm
professores que desenvolvem projetos bem
bacanas que nos proporcionam novos
espaços para desenvolver para mostrar
melhor a nossa capacidade a nossa
criatividade
estamos aqui para compartilhar um pouco
da nossa história nossas experiências e
projeto é esse
imagine se você pudesse criar um jogo
que contasse a história de sua escola e
os problemas que enfrenta
você acha que teria capacidade de criar
esse jogo
sim não talvez você acreditaria ainda
que este jogo poderia promover um novo
pensamento crítico entre os alunos
nós acreditamos que ninguém pode até
parecer uma ideia bem estranha diferente
das aulas tradicionais que muitos
professores costumam andar por aí mas
para nós criarmos jogos tem tudo a ver
com a escola queremos ter no fundo a
maioria dos estudantes que tem motivos
reais para estar na escola para fazer
algo que seja produtivo para que eles
possam mostrar seu potencial sua
capacidade ea sua criatividade
afinal todos os jovens que têm
tecnologia e não são os jovens não é
mesmo
uma pesquisa revela que 82 por cento da
população brasileira jovem adulta e 13 e
59 anos jogam jogos jogos entre as
diversas plataformas como os consoles e
pcs tablets celulares entre outros os
brasileiros passam em média mais de
cinco horas conectados em celulares
tablets e computadores
isso é por dia afinal o que é que você
aprende tanto tempo online já parou para
pensar por que os jovens gostam tanto de
tecnologia ea escola explora essa
tecnologia de forma criativa para
desenvolver novas aprendizagens dos
alunos
somos alunos de uma escola pública
carente de recursos tecnológicos
desenvolvemos o projeto de 5m e queremos
compartilhar um pouco da nossa história
e da idéia do nosso jogo com vocês
representando a voz de vários estudantes
que acreditam nesse projeto na
capacidade dos alunos
o projeto surgiu da vontade de alunos
de trabalhar em jogos digitais tudo
começou durante uma aula de reforço de
língua portuguesa com os alunos do 2º e
frente os alunos um grupo de alunos que
chamou a professora se era possível eles
aprenderem regras de acentuação através
de um jogo já está criado por eles mesmo
essa inquietação gerou novas descobertas
em nossa escola ea união de diferentes
jovens que gostem de desafios
a professora renata martins também outra
inquieta foi resolveu investir na idéia
dos alunos e foi em busca de parcerias
descobrir um projeto de verificação em
uma universidade no qual integrou o
objetivo do jogo 5 - é mostrar a mudança
em nossa escola e da nossa comunidade
que se encontra na geração jovem
utilizando tecnologias tanto na produção
quanto no jogo em si
nós fizemos uma pesquisa nesta escola
onde 88 por cento dos estudantes dos
anos finais que responderam o
questionário afirmou que jogam jogos
tanto online quanto offline
ele reconhece também que os jogos não
serve apenas para advertir que não é só
pra isso a final mas também como meio de
aprendizagem e desenvolvimento tais
coisas como inglês raciocínio lógico
criatividade a agilidade estratégia
entre outros
então nosso projeto os alunos são os
criadores modeladores e programadores
desenvolvendo pensamento computacional
mas além de toda essa parte da
tecnologia também tem baixa da história
a geografia ea avaliação dos problemas
que nossa escola enfrenta além da parte
da narrativa do jogo isso é bacana
porque é um projeto onde todas as
matérias podem integrar e ajudar eu
cheguei verificação quando se conhece a
história da escola e os problemas que
ela enfrenta é possível recriar tudo em
um jogo e colocar os alunos a pensar
criticamente sobre seus problemas
acreditamos que é possível fazer nas
escolas para criar nosso jogo nós
utilizamos o programa de modelagem
programação blender ele é um software
livre que roda no programa operacional
linux pro podendo assim ser instalado
nas escolas para desenvolver jogos em 2d
e 3d
ele permite animação e renderização
programação e modelagem desenvolvendo um
raciocínio lógico ea criatividade para a
criação de jogos obstáculos é claro que
enfrentamos os maiores obstáculos que
nós enfrentamos na nossa escola no
projeto foi justamente a falta de
recursos tecnológicos necessários para o
desenvolvimento do jogo
nós temos computadores com apenas
crianças
bati de memória então não precisamos
dizer lugar vai direto seria bacana se
nós tivéssemos alguns parceiros estão
aceitando ajuda a gente a vontade garra
nunca faltou na nossa turma que mesmo
essa professora o que faltou mesmo foi a
tecnologia a ponte temos que conseguir
um notebook compensado com uma outra
escola municipal para poder texturizada
e programar o nosso jogo ou seja nós
temos tudo pra dar errado mas com
determinação e parceiros do projeto deu
certo assim sentimos na pele que as
escolas públicas precisam de mais
investimento em tecnologia
com isso conseguimos compartilhar um
pouco do nosso conhecimento em alguns
eventos como o tic mostratec fique joão
goulart wlc 1ª e 2ª edição
lá ministramos oficina sobre blender e
agora que vocês no texas em salão
nós acreditamos que assim como o jogo
educacional consegue desenvolver a
aprendizagem específicas matérias como
matemática ciências português entre
outras
o jogo conta a história e os problemas
que uma escola enfrenta ele pode se
desenvolver um novo pensamento crítico
entre os alunos
certamente depois de tudo isso não somos
mais os mesmos
é claro mudamos a nossa forma de pensar
assim temos mais responsabilidades
aprendemos a discutir a trabalhar em
equipe até defender nossas idéias
descobrimos que temos talentos e
passamos a acreditar mais em nossa
capacidade
nós sabemos que tudo isso é o resultado
do investimento de uma professora nos
seus alunos porque até o fim eu acredito
no nosso potencial
as experiências que passamos os
conhecimentos que adquirimos resultou em
alunos dedicados em fazer a diferença
mesmo enfrentando vários obstáculos
provamos que é fundamental as escolas
investir na capacidade de seus alunos
mesmo
mesmo com vários problemas e falta de
tecnologia
juntos nós alunos e professores somos
capazes de transformar o mundo
obrigado
[Aplausos]